c'est le mec il a son coiffeur qui le
fait chier parce que son coiffeur c'est
ce que c'est les coiffeur lui connaît
tout le monde quoi il y a pas un mec qui
connaît pas quoi ils sont pas dit ça me
semble qu'un jour il revient et lui dit
bah tiens moi j'en ai une pour toi
j'allais à Rome j'ai rencontré le pape
qui dit tu me racontes des conneries
mais dis je te jure je suis arrivé
jusque dans les appartements du papa il
y a un moment je l'ai vu il venais
d'ouvrir la porte fenêtre il saluait au
balcon là la foule sur la place
Saint-Pierre il y a même un moment je
suis mis derrière lui il fait comme ça
tu as les journalistes étaient fous quoi
tout ce tour de moi en me disant qui
êtes-vous tout ça mais dis attends tu
blagues mais dis tu as parlé avec le
Saint Père mais dit comme je parle avec
toi
et ben écoute il m'a regardé la première
fois ce qui m'a dit il m'a dit c'est qui
qui t'a fait cette coupe de merde
[Applaudissements]